we're joined now by the uk's uh
environment secretary
george eustis thank you very much for
being with us um i hope you're listening
to
good morning simon covey interview um he
said that the eu won't do
a trade deal there's unanimous
agreements on that
if the uk government tries to restore
measures to the internal market bill
which break
the law are you going to try and do that
yes we will be putting those measures
back because they are very important
they just really
bring clarity to mechanisms that are
already
in the withdrawal agreement there's
already an article 16 that enables us
to act unilaterally when we need to in
order to protect the economy of northern
ireland
and in addition as well there's a
commitment to good faith which um
obviously we need the ability to
implement
so simon caveman just told me there is
an absolutely unanimous view that if the
uk decides to break international law
then why would an eu agree
the eu agreed to a deal you've just said
you are going to try and restate those
parts of the internal market bill so
should we assume that there's just not
going to be a deal
well no i think the truth is if there is
an agreement then it supersedes really
this whole debate
and that's the point of simon covenant
agreement he just said there won't be an
agreement
no but if there is an agreement then uh
the types of issues
that are causing this problem things
around things like export declarations
and
uh tariffs and one or two he's just told
me that there won't be an agreement
well if there's not an agreement that
these powers will be needed
uh if there is an agreement they won't
be needed i think he conceded that point
as well
that's why what both sides have actually
got to do is focus on getting a
withdrawal agreement we've got to we're
drawing
getting a free trade future partnership
agreement in place
and once that's done um then the types
of measures that we needed to have there
to
be able to offer legal clarity in the
event that
there's no further agreement well then
those will not be necessary
how likely do you think it is that we
are going to get a trade deal
well it's um quite difficult there are
remaining really two
sticking points one around state aid
where the eu are effectively
you know asking the uk to remain bound
um
by their system by their state aid rules
and and that's really
you know unprecedented uh for an
independent country to do that
and secondly of course around fishing
where it is a
feature of international law that a
country
has control of its exclusive economic
zone that's out to 200 miles or the
halfway point
that's what norway does what every other
country in the world does indeed it's
even what the um the eu uh have um
and it's absolutely right that the uk
should control its uh exclusive economic
zone as it leaves the eu
um fishing of course as you say is a
huge sticking point
and simon coveney just said that it is
absolutely possible that we get to a no
deal
situation overfishing and the sunday
times reports that britain wants to
reserve
at least half of the fish in british
waters for uk boats
the eu says it should be less than 20 i
mean it sounds like you're miles apart
here
well there is um some way between us i
think the principal thing is that the
the european union
seemed to believe that they could have
um at the moment their argue that they
should have sort of
effectively eternal access um you know
to our waters and
that shouldn't be varied uh from one
year to the next
uh that's obviously quite a difficult
sticking point and yes it's the case
that
at the moment the moment we have about
half of the fish in our own waters
the other half are given away to the eu
we want something
that's more balanced that's more
scientific that's uh based on
what's called zonal attachment which is
where the fish actually are to be found
and reside
that's a sensible modern scientific way
to share stocks
and yes the the eu obviously i have
enjoyed a lot of access to our water
in the past and have taken quite a lot
of fish out of our waters
i suppose it's natural they'd want to
continue that but they they do have to
accept that there are certain
consequences from
the uk leaving the eu and becoming an
independent country again
you know on this program i've spoken to
fishermen in grimsby
hastings whitspool who feel that the eu
has effectively decimated their industry
so i really
want to emphasize i do understand why
it's such a totemic issue
um but it also makes up less than 0.1
of the uk economy are we really going to
blow up
the possibility of a brexit deal over
fishing
well it's very important to coastal
communities
up and down the country and it is the
case that british fishing was damaged by
our entry
into the european union and that the
common fisheries policy has
has been a disaster and there is an
important point here um
would it be right for the uk the fifth
largest economy in the world
to be the only country in the world that
doesn't control
its own waters i think that would be
wrong there's an important
principle here as well which is the
right and the ability to manage and
control
access to your exclusive economic zone
it's what every other
country in the world has it's an
international legal norm
um so i'm interested to know a little
bit about when you think the deadline
for a deal
is going to be simon coven is saying
that there'll be real problems if one
isn't done
this week is that right
well i think both sides recognize that
time is is very very short
uh it's not long ago we were saying we
needed to get some kind of clue
conclusion by
the middle of october and people have
persevered with these talks
there does come a point frankly where
businesses need to know what they
are preparing for and does it need to be
we're not going to be
well um you can always squeeze out extra
time
if you need to if you're nearly there
but i
agree with simon covenant perhaps we can
agree on this much um
we do need this needs to be a a week
when things
move when we break through some of these
difficult issues
and get a resolution at least have some
sort of um headlines if you like of an
agreement
you know otherwise it gets quite
difficult and we do start to run out of
time to implement it
okay good to see a bit of an agreement
with simon copeland because it doesn't
appear that you've agreed on
that much else on the program this
morning we can agree on the timings if
not who should move
yeah exactly is it easier to get a deal
done without dominic cummings
well look the negotiations have been uh
led by david frost
from the beginning he's got a very
talented experienced team of technical
experts around him
uh he's led these negotiations from the
start and obviously remains in place and
continues to do so
so i don't actually think um the
departure of dominic cummings
makes any particular impact on the
negotiations since uh
lord frost has been leading those has of
course been
a pretty extraordinary week though a
distracting week as well i just want to
look at some of the briefing that's been
coming out of number 10 because it's
some of the most toxic that i can
remember carrie simmons referred to as
princess nut nut
this about lee kane a rude needlessly
abrasive
insecure clown with no brain for
government
this about dominic cummings that's the
last time he walks down the road like
kim kardashian
preening for the cameras like the
spoiled lord of barnard castle i mean
this is
toxic soap opera stuff
what's your reaction been when you've
seen what people are saying
in number 10 have you been embarrassed
have you been incredulous has you been
angry
well look it is inevitable that when you
get episodes like this there will always
be
a lot of intense media interest in the
gossip
of who said what to who and rival
briefings and so forth and of course
that finds
uh you know particularly uh fertile
ground in the sunday papers
above sorry i'm going to come in there
because it's it's so predictable that
you blame the media for it but
it's coming out of number 10. it's
coming out some of the most senior
figures
in number 10. the prime minister has
just lost two of his closest aides
i just think it's unfair just to say
this is just the sunday papers doing
what they always do
what's your human reaction been to it
because she must have had one
well like i'm not blaming the sunday
papers clearly if colorful turns a
phrase like that
are relayed in anonymous background
briefings
of course people will use them and they
will write stories with them i'm just
saying that for me
as a cabinet minister and and every
other cabinet missile is the same
we've been getting on with our jobs this
week i've put forward an agriculture
bill that's got right
work on the spending review um continues
we're making good progress on
uh vaccines and that's preoccupying matt
hancock
for those of us in the cabinet um we
don't tend to immerse ourselves in the
the gossip
of who said what to whom on episodes
such as this
okay this gossip as you say this
distraction is happening
in the middle of a pandemic just as
brexit talks enter
the most crucial stage as you say
there's lots going on spending review
etc
some would say the blame lies with the
prime minister he's the person
in charge he sets the tone does he need
to take some responsibility
for the fact that his staff are tearing
strips off each other
well look i think um what i would say
here i've known dominic cummings myself
for
many years he's got many uh great
strengths and
um one of them is winning campaigns and
he tends to
apply himself in short bursts short
tools of duty
on big strategic changes such as the
2016 referendum results such as the
2019 general election and he's very
talented
at that but look it's the always the
prime minister's derogative who
will be their key advisors the prime
minister has to have a team around him
that he's comfortable with
uh that works well to get the right
balance and it's always the case that
prime ministers can
change their advisors and change the mix
of their advisors
um some would say that part of the issue
is that the prime minister hasn't been
decisive
enough previously you know he offered
lee kane the chief of staff
job then it didn't happen he put out a
statement saying he would stay until the
new year
lee kane and then two days later he
asked him to leave downing street
is this a prime minister who just agrees
with whoever the last person he spoke to
was
no i think that's unfair you know this
is a prime minister who's dealing with
some
extraordinary challenges facing our
country
with this global pandemic and he's
having to make multiple decisions
every week about an emerging situation
in this most difficult
of challenges so i don't accept this uh
charge that the prime minister's
indecisive
he's making decisions all the time uh
but he and uh leaders right around the
world are operating clearly in a very
difficult context
okay a difficult context uh certainly
and should we move on to
that difficult context the pandemic of
course coveted 19 something that is
hugely on the mind of all of our viewers
and all of us and the news that the
fines the vaccine
is 90 effective it's been a real boost
this week
and we're also of course expecting the
oxford astropytheneco results to be
posted the next few weeks
could we start seeing a vaccine being
rolled out before christmas
well it's it's possible and the chief
medical officer
has said that there's a possibility you
could start deploying the vaccine
before christmas but we we must get our
hopes up there is still
more to do the uk on the fisa vaccine
has already got access to
40 million doses some of those are
already being manufactured
all of these vaccines are several
different candidates now
you know are in the final approval
stages
obviously we need to make sure that they
are safe to use and there's a
rigorous approval process for that
reason
but yes um there has been some
encouraging progress on a number of
vaccines not least the
fisa one and i think it does uh you know
open out the
the prospect uh that we can start to
roll out that vaccine particularly in
the early part of
uh next year and hopefully this will
help us turn the corner
on this very difficult pandemic during
the course of next summer
it's so great to have a bit of light
potentially at the end of the tunnel and
but as you say big logistical challenges
too
the sheer number of people who need to
be vaccinated also the fact that the
fisa vaccine needs to be
stored at such low temperatures and
just after your interview we'll show a
short film that i did about vaccines i
spoke to the leader of imperial's
vaccine team who said that we're
unlikely to really see a
return to normality until next summer
that we'll need social distancing face
masks etc probably until
halfway through next year do you think
that's right
well i think it's very difficult to
predict obviously the moment we're in
uh this current set of restrictions a
second lockdown if you like
that's going to be reviewed at the end
of this month
and on the 2nd of december new steps
will come into place there will need to
be undoubtedly some
sort of restrictions from the 2nd of
december for for a little while but
it's too early to judge yet exactly what
those particular restrictions will be
and of course the thing to remember is
once you get into spring and summer
the weather conditions become less
conducive to the spread of the virus
that's what we saw
happening last year and so the
combination of the deployment of a
vaccine
and the arrival of summer does offer
quite a lot of hope that we can
really start to get this virus under
control fingers crossed
certainly um just finally this week
marks a bit of a reset
for uh the prime minister we're
expecting the environment to be
a big focus of the government if you
like you've got an announcement today on
parks is this all part of the new look
administration well
this has actually been part of the
government agenda
from the beginning when i was appointed
the prime minister said he really wanted
me to focus on
issues like climate change it's a big
challenge
facing the whole world and also to
improve nature
and wildlife and our natural environment
so what we've committed to do is to
protect
30 percent of our landscapes by 2030 and
we'll be doing that by
you know rolling out additional national
parks and
areas of outstanding natural beauty and
other protected areas too
and managing them better so that we can
really build back habitats and wildlife
in some of these protected sites okay
george eustis thank you very much for
coming the program today thank you
thank you very much